in the chill of an evening in Sweden a
freeze returned to negotiations between
the u.s. and North Korea the two sites
have been meeting in Stockholm for the
first time since previous nuclear talks
broke down at a field summit in Vietnam
in February but it quickly became clear
the two are dramatically far apart the
u.s. raised expectations by offering
suggestions like a flexible approach new
method and creative solutions but they
have disappointed us greatly and dampen
our enthusiasm for negotiations by
bringing nothing to the negotiation
table both sides agreed to restart the
talks after Donald Trump's remarkable
visit to North Korea in June at the end
of the g7 in Japan he met the North
Korean president Kim jong-un at the
demilitarized zone the area marking the
border between North and South Korea and
then took the dramatic step over the
border the first u.s. president to do so
there was hope fresh talks might make
progress after President Trump's
national security adviser John Bolton
was fired he was seen by the north as an
obstacle to a deal he admitted he was
deeply skeptical they would ever give up
their nuclear weapons and a day after
the new talks were announced Pyongyang
confirmed it had test-fired a ballistic
missile designed for a submarine launch
a step forward in technology and a clear
message to the Americans even a few
hours before the talks broke down US
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo was
confident of a breakthrough there were
four pillars that the two leaders agreed
to and we were very hopeful that we will
make some progress we're mindful this
will be the first time we've had a
chance to have a discussion and quite
sometime in a statement the State
Department said the United States and
the DPRK North Korea will not overcome a
legacy of 70 years of war and hostility
on the Korean Peninsula through the
course of a single Saturday these are
weighty issues and they require a strong
commitment by both countries the United
States has that commitment the US says
it has accepted an invitation from the
Swedes to return for more talks in two
weeks time for their part the North
Koreans say the denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula is still possible but
only when obstacles that threaten their
safety and check their development
removed completely without a shadow of
doubt that suggests that until the US
starts to ease sanctions on North Korea
they won't be going back to the
negotiating table Alan Fisher al Jazeera
Washington